trending earlier and i think
it was because
of his response to joe rogan i have not
watched it i have not seen this but
we'll go through the thread here and we
will
we will try and
find the video find the footage we'll
find the footage here
because that's what we do on the [ __ ]
list roundup we ran up all the tweety
tweets and the trendy trends uh tuck
trump says uh here it's a huffington
post article uh trevor noah pats pence
on the back for trying new things
trying new things let's try some new
[ __ ] now you guys know that um mike
pence basically told uh trump to go [ __ ]
himself and then he's a goddamn loser i
mean he didn't say those words but he
pretty much aimed he called him an
american basically said you lost [ __ ]
get over it you lost [ __ ]
but here is joe uh here's his um
it looks like his statements to joe
rogan about planet of the apes
let's see
yeah and this is the daily show account
so we'll play it off here now they're
probably going to ding me on this
because they own this the daily show and
comedy center on this
so they're probably if if we play this
video later on in the week this part
will probably be silence when i show
this video but here we go even though
rogan apologized um this was strange a
lot of people were arguing sort of
against his apology saying that the
n-word with context is totally fine for
a white person to say yeah
you know and i i i understand what the
so so uh you know that was the right of
the argument that's what we were saying
earlier
with me and gabe is that these people
think that if you if you just change the
context that maybe that word's okay
which it may or may not be but that's
not the point because really honestly if
you look at joe rogan's word inside the
context it's racist as [ __ ]
they're saying like you know maybe
you're a professor teaching history
maybe you're a news anchor reporting on
a story about your rogan right maybe
you're in a quentin tarantino movie and
you have to use the n-word because if
you don't
then the movie has no dialogue
he makes he makes a decent point there
that quentin tarantino
definitely ratchets up the temperature
in a movie yeah of course quentin
tarantino has been
has been slammed for that for years and
then the actors have stood up for him
and that sort of thing and it's in a
script so you know that that i i guess
maybe that's a discussion you can have
about whether that rather that [ __ ]
word should be in those movies it's the
same discussion you you could have about
the the book to kill a mockingbird or
the inventors of huckleberry finn
right
but
but
for the most part as a white person
you never need to use the n-word it's
not like need for example i've gone this
entire story saying the n-word and
everyone has understood exactly what
i've meant
exactly
exactly
they're all just sounds right it's
sounds right and words are sounds but
you know it's it's the [ __ ] let's go
brand and [ __ ] too
sometimes we can't say what we want to
say so we say other things as humans
right
nobody's sitting at home going nutella
neanderthal
nelly furtado why is trevor being so
vague what is the word in fact here's a
here's a life hack for white people
saying the actual n-word
puts you in unnecessary trouble
especially
if you're not racist
it doesn't matter the context because
black people don't have the time to sit
down and sort out the racist who says
the n-word 70 times with the non-racist
who says the n-word 70 times
what a great point
what a great point because white people
do this thing why people do this look
look around thing
like when they're going to tell a
certain joke or they're going to say
something you know that they they know
if someone with an earshot of what what
trevor's saying here because
um you know and white people know this
so they do the
they look around before they say what
they're gonna say
and it's a it's a great point black
people are dealing with too much [ __ ] no
no look look at how i was using it
no one's got the time for that just stop
saying it or just be racist that's right
it's easy
yep
so look and i'm with trevor on this just
be racist if you want to be racist just
be [ __ ] racist just say it out loud
you know what i was so disappointed in
is that is that donald trump just didn't
come out and say the word
that these these people don't just get
in front of a microphone and say the
words so we know for sure
like context or no context we know for
sure
who you are
and a little bit of that is the silver
lining behind trump is now we know who
these people are
i'm glad i'm glad that joe rogan has
gone you know what i don't i didn't need
to use that word all those times because
people need to learn and i'm glad that
he has right so joe rogan is saying that
him using the word in context wasn't
racist but it was ignorant and not cool
okay fine but don't forget
there's also the story
where joe rogan calls black people apes
and this and this is this is part of the
video
um that he's going to point out here
this is this is not something that like
someone secretly recorded joe rogan
saying
right this story that he's about to show
and i don't know if trevor's gonna show
it here but this is the story
um of where he's going to see the movie
playing into the apes
joe rogan not only [ __ ] recorded it
edit it and then publish the [ __ ] for
people to hear him saying it
okay
he published it he wanted people to hear
himself say this story to tell the story
and so for that part of the apology
joe rogan says this
i did not nor would i ever
say that black people are apes but it
sure [ __ ] sounded like that i was
just saying there's a lot of black
people there but then i went on to talk
about what a positive experience it was
and how much
oh well well and i'm sure trevor is
going to do much better job than me here
but oh well well that makes it great
fun it was to go to see this movie in a
black neighborhood it wasn't a racist
story but it sounded terrible it's a
[ __ ] idiotic thing to say
and i was just trying to be entertaining
i certainly wasn't trying to be racist
and see it's just it's this hiding
behind comedy thing right and and joe
rogan for all intents and purposes and
parts of his commentary he is a comedian
he does stand up but when he's talking
in front of microphones like that it's
not always comedy and people aren't
taking it as comedy they're taking into
serious commentary
right now we use comedy on this show to
keep your attention and make you
entertained so that you tune in
that we do it we'll admit to it
but work what we're doing is giving
serious political commentary i'm not
[ __ ] around
i'm dead serious about the [ __ ] i say
now yeah i mean obviously we use comedy
and we exaggerate when we're using
comedy but the commentary in and of
itself
it's about serious [ __ ] subjects
serious [ __ ] things yeah i caught the
[ __ ] list roundup and and we go through
the tweety tweets and the trendy trends
but it's serious [ __ ] real life [ __ ]
this affects [ __ ] human
beings i certainly
would
never want to offend someone
for entertainment with something as
stupid as racism all right i'm not gonna
lie i have a few issues with this part
of the video first of all he says he
would never say black people are apes
but he said that right he that's
literally what he said if you said you
walked into a black place and it was
planet of the apes then you've said that
you said you can't be like i didn't say
you did say it which is racist right
and it's not just racist like let's
let's be honest about it's not just
right that's like og racism that's like
like the original old school like that's
on the mount rushmore of racism you know
black people are apes it's right next to
burning crosses and then like every bugs
bunny cartoon from the 1940s
what i found particularly illuminating
is is when he says
i wasn't being racist
i was just being entertaining
no joe i think you were using racism to
be entertaining that's right
you say what i'm saying i'm not saying
he's entertaining racist
that's what he's doing
he's there he's their jester right
that's the whole point that's why these
[ __ ] are calling the mizella's brothers
these stoolies and these [ __ ]
roganites
and committing death threats
is because he's entertaining them
with racism you were trying to offend
black people by the way but you knew
that offending black people would get a
laugh out of those white friends that
you were with
and please understand this understand
this guy i'm a comedian
right which you would know if i had a
live audience right now
it would be like
probably the
yeah but i am a comedian and i love
making jokes and i love hearing jokes
and i love i love all kinds of jokes
right i love safe jokes i like dark
jokes i like jokes but just because
something is a joke
doesn't mean it can't be something else
as well because a joke can be racist
right in fact a joke can be racist and
funny if you're telling it to the right
crowd it's no joke it's never for yeah
someone can find it funny but the laughs
don't mean that there's no racism think
of it this way think of this right if i
rob a bank
and i get busted i can't defend myself
by saying no guys i did it as a joke
yeah but you pistol whipped the bank
teller yeah but but i made a funny it
was funny
and he's going to make good points here
but i do want to say back to the point
that i was trying to make of joe rogan
being the jester is that that's what
he's doing and that's what spotify did
that's what i want people understand
about spotify because they're i've
gotten some a little bit of heat saying
that i'm not gonna leave spotify i'm not
gonna de-platform myself and i really
don't give a [ __ ] if you don't like that
i d platform myself from spotify fine
whatever i don't give a [ __ ] that's my
choice it's just like it's spotify's
choice and joe rogan's choice to stay on
spotify it's completely their choice i
mean i i know trevor here probably i i
know they have a podcast it probably
goes on spotify too and here he is here
he is bashing rogan so they had to make
a choice whether they're going to stay
on spotify or not and it really is
shitty that we have to make those
choices but that's what we have to do
but i feel like i'm not talking and i'm
not [ __ ]
making entertainment
right
for racist
the racists aren't tuning in here
being like oh tony's really funny oh
he's so great
he says all the things i want to hear no
that's not what they're doing i mean if
they came here they wouldn't get they
wouldn't get a load of that
i mean we have people here that disagree
with me
that are in the comments we have people
that i have people that comment all the
time that disagree with me politically a
lot of times our political arguments are
thin you know they're like oh you wear a
backwards hat cool like okay yeah but
not much of a argument against my
political beliefs but yeah you know i i
look like i'm fred durst from the 90s
sure great okay great great comeback
on how to fix education in the country
fantastic
we know now
why we need to fix education because of
comments like that
but they don't get up in my [ __ ]
comments and say racist [ __ ]
they don't because i'm [ __ ] white
because i'm [ __ ] white they don't say
racist [ __ ] to me
i mean i've got the whole race trader
thing before but they don't even do that
much
it's because i'm white
it's because the audience that joe rogan
placates to and he's entertaining are a
bunch of [ __ ] fragile male white
racist
that's what it is
that's who the audience is that's who
spotify purchased spotify doesn't give a
[ __ ] about rogan everyone thinks he's
they're trying to protect rogan they
don't give a [ __ ] about rogan
rogan's just the token to their [ __ ]
atm
don't you get it it's capitalism spotify
would put someone else in his place and
pay them a hundred million dollars if
they knew they could sell advertising to
that racist [ __ ] that racist [ __ ]
audience
and that's where some people had the
problem with spotify and i'm fine with
that
i'm fine that you have that problem with
spotify and you should do what you want
to do
just like i'm going to do what i want to
do and and do it in the way that i'm
going to do it i'm gonna keep yelling in
this microphone and i'll call spotify
out hell this podcast is on spotify
they're trying to placate the rogan's
racist audience
now rather joe rogan intentionally did
that or not but over the years joe rogan
has developed and built a huge [ __ ]
white male fragile [ __ ] macho
machismo racist
[ __ ]
maga type trump type audience that's
what he's done that's what spotify
bought they bought the exclusive rights
to pump ads to that audience
and that is probably the best argument
for someone to take their take their
[ __ ] subscription and tell spotify to
go [ __ ]
themselves that's probably the best
argument is that spotify is placating to
not joe rogan
but his [ __ ] racist audience
he sound when i did it i was like
give me the money [ __ ]
so do i get to go now so yeah joe rogan
is saying that he would never say
something racist
and now because of that obviously in the
video a lot of his fans are like yeah he
would never say something racist it's
just a joke you guys are uptight he
would never say something racist a joke
is not racist and you know what i can
have my opinion
and you can have your opinion fine
but you know whose opinion i think
matches more than most people
is joe rogan
and here's what joe rogan said about his
joke when he said it
we walk into planet of the apes
we walked into africa dude we we we
walked in the door and there was no
white people there was no white people
we planted the eggs didn't take place in
africa that was a racist thing
yeah exactly it is a racist thing for
you to say you're saying it's racist but
then in the video you're going to be
like
joe rogan said a racist thing and then
immediately acknowledged that it was
racist literally when he said it he said
it and then he's like oh that was racist
and now he's like i would never never
say racist like you know this whole
thing makes me go like why are people so
adamant
that it wasn't racist
why like why do people people do a thing
that's racist and then they go like no
it's not race can i can i be honest with
you honestly i'm not a scholar i'm not
like the whatever this is my opinion i
think it's because people are just truly
petrified of having the label racist
branded on them for life that's what
people are really afraid of no one wants
to be called a racist because then
they're like how long am i a racist for
does it like am i racist for life am i
racist i can't get jobs am i right no no
i just want to be racist but i don't
want to be called a racist which is
understandable
but it also makes people unable to admit
when they say or do something racist
right they would rather down the hill of
them not being racist even if it means
giving convoluted excuses that don't
make any sense
it's a great great clip from trevor
trevor
thank you trevor
for explaining that um
from your from his perspective and you
gotta remember
trevor noah
is not from america he's from south
africa so he is seeing different styles
and a different dichotomy of racism
altogether um than what we have seen in
this country i mean it's it you know it
it's it's a it was a completely
different world because
he's he's a mixed race and he lived
under apartheid and then not under
apartheid um so he has a unique
perspective i think uh in racism in and
of itself not just in this country but
racism in general so i appreciate trevor
speaking up and giving the world his
view on why joe rogan is racist after
joe rogan
called himself said oh that's what i
just said was racist
so
thank you very much trevor okay we are
we are past the second hour that trevor
noah's stuff um took us in all the way
to the end i appreciate trevor verde
again
we may have to silence the video youtube
may cut us off
this fair use thing is kind of a touchy
you know like how much you play what is
is it actual commentary or are you
commentating on commentary you know is
it is trevor noah a news story so
there's a lot of there's a lot of gray
area but there's a lot of
fences up for